près de trois Français sur 4 mécontents
d'Emmanuel Macron c'est l'enseignement
du sondage
Ifop le JDD publié ce dimanche pire
encore les traits atteignent un niveau
record 47 % de nos concitoyens quasi la
moitié finalement c'est donc son
troisième mois consécutif de chute se
ressemblent de la part d'Emmanuel Macron
que de la distance de la brutalité
de la violence institutionnelle du
mépris de l'arrogance
cette partie de ceux qui pensent que le
Président de la République ne pourra pas
tenir 4 ans de plus en ce contexte
j'entends cela depuis 1981
on disait déjà que François Mitterrand
ne tiendrait pas son septennat il en a
fait deux il a fait 14
donc voyez ce que je pense de ce genre
de d'analyse et de rumeurs Emmanuel
Macron
pourquoi avoir
choisi l'image des 100 jours alors que
vous savez comment ça s'est terminé
certes il y a effectivement des concerts
de casserole d'ailleurs souvent mis en
place orchestrée salam orchestré par
l'extrême gauche par la CGT par la
France insoumise mais ça n'empêche pas
le président aussi de pouvoir discuter
avec avec les français Laurent Berger
vous allez prendre votre retraite en
juin à 54 ans est-ce que ce n'est pas un
peu tôt
on a l'impression que le quinquennat est
terminé déjà il va faire des petits
débats on a vu quelques images tout à
l'heure il est sur le terrain il échange
avec des gens une fois que les
casseroles s'éteignent il y a des gens
qui sont d'accord et des gens qui ne
sont pas d'accord qui sont prêts à
échanger avec lui Gérard Larcher
également qui réagit dans les colonnes
du Parisien ce matin il parle de crise
de confiance il essaye de donner
quelques conseils au président de la
République et il dit voilà il faut
retrouver la proximité avec les Français
monsieur le Président il ne fera pas en
100 jours ce qui n'a pas fait en six ans
de Girard Larcher ce matin est-ce que
vous êtes d'accord avec ça oui je suis
bon cette expression des 100 jours bon
d'abord on connaît l'histoire pas
forcément porteuse de succès mais
j'allais dire histoire est presque dites
sur les retraites mais surtout nous
projeter vers l'avenir
la phrase importante je pense c'est la
prospérité et la condition de la justice
on a un présent de la République quand
on lui parle et que les gens se
mobilisent il explique que les
casseroles et les œufs c'est pour
cuisiner mais est-ce qu'ils se rend
compte l'état dans lequel est le pays
c'est Frédéric Beigbeder qui a été prise
à partir par des féministes avec cette
librairie Mola qui a été donc dégradé
moi je pense que le pays va très mal je
pense que le pays se meurt doucement que
nous sommes à la fois en déclin
économique social culturelle
intellectuel scolaire et en plus victime
d'un grand remplacement de population
c'est grave ce qui est en train de se
passer c'est très grave c'est la liberté
d'expression qui est en jeu mais c'est
un exemple parmi tant d'autres et
malheureusement c'est au Soudan les
combats se poursuivent dans la capitale
Khartoum malgré les appels au
cessez-le-feu pour la fin du ramadan pas
de sursis pour les populations civiles
la situation humanitaire est
catastrophique dans de nombreuses
régions du pays c'est dans ce contexte
incertain que la France tente d'évacuer
250 ressortissants ainsi que des
Européens premier danger rejoindre les
points de ralliement une réunion de
crise a lieu actuellement au ministère
des Affaires étrangères vous voyez ces
images avec notamment la ministre
Catherine Colona auront jamais à l'abri
de rien donc tout ce qui confine à faire
en sorte que nos ressortissants nos
expatriés puissent être mis en sécurité
va dans le bon sens
de cartoon dans le Tarn la mobilisation
des opposants à l'autoroute a69 qui doit
relier Castres à Toulouse se poursuit
aujourd'hui ils étaient environ 4500
militants écologistes hier selon la
préfecture un peu plus de 8000 d'après
les organisateurs c'est vraiment un
projet enfin complètement dépassé on
parle d'anéantissement de la
biodiversité sandre
[Rires]
est-ce qu'il y a un seul homme au monde
que vous admirez
[Applaudissements]